welcome to this video playing Chris
stuff Chris Stefan okay and then you
come in Italian game let's see I don't
really know the Evans gambit you let's
play let's play normal stuff this
classical line with c3 and d3 leads to
leads to a long-winded strategic battle
it's normally so why not you can think
of rookie won this Knight g4 h3 that's
night h5 i'm not mistaken
laughter I don't remember I mean I play
this is black of course but I normally
just play h6 earlier at Bishop e6 maybe
you can go nite h5 now
now can you rate at 50 maybe 94 is plate
so that I can really just capture this
night should it come to a form
and whenever if he goes King a jade is
it an idea to play m95 Oh be five I
didn't expect that move weakening the
queenside quite substantially and I have
95 as a as a movement yeah here for
example 95 let's let's just do that not
waste much time where he can play night
x h3 here that this may be really on
nope didn't do that so hmm may I can
open up their file I'm not sure if black
should take now and slap the look on f1
so the move you like to play that much
of the capture okay I thought deform
maybe putting some additional pressure
on e5 makes it less attractive I'm to
play moves like 97 for example okay so
may be here for Queen g3 and then
doubling on their farm
ok it seems that he wants to go see 6 cm
Queen g36
it's not that bad for me c6 Bishop b3 if
it takes it yeah if it takes it I have
an attack on a six immediately and if he
takes d4 then d6 if he takes d4 d6 gets
weak pressurized by the Queen on g3 okie
dokie so maybe Eric F 2 there's no need
to cover you for Allah whenever he takes
d6 will be much weaker I mean a much
more important weakness than my my
pointy form I think double on there for
him it's really taking his sweet time oh
I guess I have to take now
hmm yeah tough maybe I guess the default
is more important here now than the FR
know that the bishop is gone so i'm
going to do something with the rooks
there whenever he captures it it just
says no difference in power Jake's oops
oops I didn't think about that one at
all okay yeah let's take here fe for I
take these six with the temple this
should be really good and pawn takes
rook fd2 for example looks looks kind of
problematic
okay if I cheek now yeah it's not that
bad for him
yeah fatigue f5 there is Bishop f5 and
possibly possibly trouble on but ok wait
I can take that play efore Bishop takes
e4 Bishop takes you four look at these
seven this check on civ 5 but it's still
interesting yeah I'm on this I'm on one
g7
this is the idea Bishop before luke t
seven is good for white I get to the g7
upon and I'm intending to play nitey one
now trying to expel this Bishop not
totally sure about this but I had to had
to move something maybe also oh I
thought that this wasn't working at all
how are you covering g7 now a queen a
fire for not getting checkmated this is
the point on Queen F royal it can play
that and avoid the maid check okay
time warning Jim surprising surprising
that this summer holes is black put to
death okay check check John I have the
far better pawn structure here so it is
not yeah it is not bad or anything for
me check yeah this is this is a good
movie 'um
check kingi one
amazing I'm check it this wasn't that
bad check kam SE pone this is some quite
a problem yeah how very difficult stuff
cannot really lack resign the sisters
properly let's have a look I wondered
here if he may be can take on edge 3m
it's the supportability this kind of
thing routine one but he has no way to
get the Queen involved this is the main
issue something like this i have this
move for a queen a 3m okay that's that's
really nothing big stakes this seems all
fairly fairly normal like black should
be okay him I think can't hear you went
with this f5 looks really does this
looks like to weakening but I'm how many
did not exploit it our queen h4
interesting that's a good move here yeah
once you see it it gets apparent quite
quickly because well this is really bad
yeah this is a double attack on those
two so we can blacken or take and if he
takes here this screen is excellent here
here fantastic and it's really not so
clear what black should do now slightly
awkward
situation compounds to do this but this
is a rather clear advantage and
something like this spawn structure is
simply too too weak yeah that was good I
went here Thanks yeah my original
intention was to do this but he has this
check this kind of sports had a thought
but this is actually not bad Bishop g6 I
have this move with interesting play hmm
top could have done that I was just
trying to trap him in a way with this
and he really took Kruger for as much
better but this is really should be good
now right check rook a7s button okay
check check check now maybe I could have
taken immediately GM okay rookie to as a
mistake no why is this a mistake know
now that another confessor is correcting
this yeah white is much better okay
jealous this is also what i thought
because well my king is playing and this
is a factor i get to the c6 porn really
quickly yeah it's the case where this
point on the queenside they are just
much more dangerous yeah okay well
thanks for watching